the underlying current when people write
about you yeah who the [ __ ] is this guy
yeah I mean you get that right of course
Guardian this is a word that is rarely
talked about in our space that I want to
start building more attention for
self-awareness I want to deliver on this
message so much that would create a test
or or a drug that allowed people to
become self-aware one potion inject not
hustle not smart self-awareness I don't
fear being self-aware I know I suck at a
lot of stuff I think everybody lies for
themselves some people are meant to be
D&C players and I'm pissed that the
narrative now is that you need to be a
number one and have your company because
a lot of people gonna lose or leave
money on the table because that's just
the narrative some such a positive guy I
struggle to think about the things I'm
bad at but you know self-awareness
requires understanding both and then
choosing which path you want to go
through I'm a big fan of going all in
under strengths and don't give a [ __ ]
about where you suck at sub witness
isn't only just betting on your
strengths it's accepting all your
shortcomings let me tell you one thing
what works for me does not necessarily
work for you I think being a peace with
yourself and your skill set is such an
important part of this too many people
try to be like me because it's Sicily
and it's sexy and people want to be
charismatic and on stage so many of you
do so many things better than I do you
can look at like how people roll and
like it's great to admire and things of
that nature but it's so damn important
to stick to like your DNA try to get to
a place where you understand yourself
and understand what your strengths are
you've got to find your self-awareness
all your shortcomings are there for a
reason they're there to also allow you
to be great deep in your brain deep in
your heart you actually accept all those
shortcomings is the second your life
goes on the offense I worry that people
don't tap into their strengths you have
to audit who you are
so you are because then you're not going
to [ __ ] yourself even a story tell
yourself you can motivate yourself but
you're not going to [ __ ] yourself
and once you believe that either for
yourself or someone else told you go
directly all chips all into that we've
all got something and you just need to
accept what's yours and go in on that
then you've got a starting point to
success and so self-awareness at its
finest is accepting your shortcomings
and accentuating your strengths are you
I'm an entrepreneur